I've done to the point where I will go
through an entire day of just having the
little bit of garnish on my feet and
count that as my vegetable for the day
well I've been vegan for a year some of
you might think oh so she must be really
healthy eat a lot of vegetables I've
been feeling really lethargic lately I'm
hoping that you know fresh vegetables
might change that for women 19 to 30
should have one and a half cups of dark
green vegetables 5.5 cups of bread and
orange vegetables and five cups of
starch vegetables although hello how
does a cup I'm sure it seems like what
I'm thinking about it I have to eat two
cups of dark green vegetables 6 cups of
red green vegetables 6 cups of starchy
vegetables I feel like I'm just gonna
poop a lot this week I don't know where
to start because I don't know what's
doing any of them I'm realizing I don't
really know how much is a serving of
certain foods a good thing about its
challenge is that I'm gonna have to
still be anything so I'm gonna put
cheese but a lot of things to make it
taste better
yay cheese so today for lunch I have
this Pizza vegan cookbook for beginners
and there's no like whole category for
cooking vegetables they're like [ __ ]
you should know by now so I'm at brunch
and originally I was gonna get the hang
of the killer scramble but since I'm
making an effort I'm gonna eat the
Angelino veggie 2.0 it actually looks
really good I'm pretty sure this counts
for like two servings at the least okay
well I guess I'll just do a cup peas
which means I need another cup and half
vegetables by the end of the day which
seems like frickin long I've realized
something horrible everything is
measured and cut for my rosemary roasted
vegetables
and I look at my spice rack and I have
no rosemary so I'm cooking a stir-fry
and I am gonna put red pepper in it
but I just feel like most of all I eat
is like the leafy greens how many
vegetables all that are really red and
orange that's like so specific
I mean claw and let us leave but that's
gonna be wrapped in this so I don't even
know if this counts as a complete
serving salads from Ralphs and I'm gonna
add some more leafy greens good what
never have too many of them cuz I gotta
get through this now it's like and
forget about it thrust today which is
not how you're supposed to do it my
veggies look sort of wilted I couldn't
do you guys I couldn't have finished
them oh my god they're so dry so I'm
pretty impressed with myself because
last night I actually meal prep don't
look at this
Joe is judging my salad
you know tomatoes are technically a
fruit right I can't be friends how do
you feel about the idea of eating that
many vegetables in a week there's gonna
be a lot of parts ain't more than uh
yesterday
oh no no so I made noodles then I made
this salad I am like attracted to the
salad you know I really feel like this
challenge has sort of changed my ways
after this whole week I've been very
regular I definitely think in the long
run it would they would absolutely help
me with like energy levels and stuff
like that I definitely want to carry on
with this and do this like as a
lifestyle don't hate vegetables I've
never hated vegetables I actually don't
like fruit punch
[Music]